[Music]
hello thank you for joining my name is
Tina toshko and I'm a product manager on
Google bigquery did anybody see that
keynote the the CTO of go-jek arrived on
stage and a moped it was amazing
well I'm joined on stage today with
folks from Home Depot Rick and Kevin I
am going to disappoint guys they're not
going to make the arrival on a lawnmower
right they're just gonna walk on stage
sorry we didn't come prepared but in all
seriousness this is a fantastic story
I'm looking forward to hearing Rick and
Kevin talk about it because one thing is
to be a start-up but to be born in the
cloud and to build your infrastructure
you know with with bespoke requirements
the other is to have a complex
multinational organization with online
with mobile with brick and mortar
presence and hundreds of thousands of
SKUs and professional services and many
many years of technology innovation and
and really smart engineers and how do
you move that into the the modern world
Rick and Kevin are going to be talking
about and so we're going to talk about
is the concept of a data warehouse right
there it's a really novel idea right
we're gonna take all our data and we're
gonna put it into one place and then
we're going to create and analyze it and
we're gonna be data driven awesome but
the reality is that data warehousing is
really difficult it's challenging it's
the complexity piles on as your business
grows especially right it gets really
really difficult to start getting
business value out of technology so much
so that technology can stand in the way
of your business which is the last thing
you wanted to do right technology should
be an accelerator of your business so
it's really you know with the advent of
cloud and cloud native technologies and
the scalability and higher level of
manageability maybe perhaps it's time to
rethink what a cloud what a better where
really means so the query is the world's
only service data warehouse service of
course is a buzzword but what do we mean
by that we mean that we entirely
abstract away hardware we provide a very
very high level of manageability
automation API first we provide
virtually unlimited scalability low
effort low maintenance to to reach and
maintain peak performance and so on and
so forth right
having the ability to share data without
moving the data around bringing people
to the data around the other way around
right and we really have evolved as a
service over the past six years these
are some of the things that we've
delivered as features to our customers
of the past years that really make it
easier for folks to run a data warehouse
on top of bigquery well today we
announced a number of really really
interesting features and I'll walk you
guys there are some of these of course
you've heard about declarative machine
learning in bigquery which brings
machine learning to the analyst right
folks don't need to know tensor flow or
care as when you do this really really
complex technologies they can just use
plain old sequel to to prototype and
train machine learning models let's talk
about one of those features clustering
if in this particular example I have a
query that is selecting a date and user
ID
well clustering increases data locality
for high-carbon out of the fields so
that if you apply clustering on your
tables you get vast improvements and
cost that's the promise and efficiency
or performance in some cases the
performance can be ten or a hundred
times better than without clustering and
actually at three o'clock jordan tegami
and lloyd Tabb are going to be doing a
lot of demonstration of clustering you
should not miss it we also announced a
new bigquery UI right so it's material
design it's an o'clock class so it's
localized to all the different regions
that don't necessarily speak English
with other great benefits for example
data studio Explorer which allows you to
pop out your results of your queries
into Data studio for for interactive
pivoting and further analysis one
feature that we haven't really discussed
too much but we've had for a while at
Home Depot
talk about a little bit in a little bit
more detail is hierarchical reservations
so for complex enterprises that need
isolation and resource guarantees that
would like to have more control more
knobs in their enterprise data warehouse
are able to create this hierarchical
reservation trees that the really you
know guarantee resources for specific
purposes but also the beauty of this is
that these aren't you know silos of
resources if a data science project is
idle for some reason right that a
science team went on vacation and those
reese's are unused transparently
seamlessly down to sub second latency
those resources become available for the
rest of the organization to use so as as
other teams continue to scale on the
query the entire organization benefits
right you get economies of scale and of
course one very challenging aspect of
running a data warehouse is ingest we
hear this from customers all the time
how do I get data into my data warehouse
how do I get it so that the status fresh
and available right away and it doesn't
compete with my query capacity and we've
really invested heavily in in our ingest
capabilities right our batch ingest is
free it's powerful
we have customers loading petabytes of
data into the query every single day
without affecting their query
performance even one bit right and of
course we have a streaming API on the
other side which gives you access to
your data in the real time
but enterprises heavily rely on not just
on native bespoke tools provided by
cloud vendors but on their partner
ecosystem right so if you're a large
organization that have a history of
technology innovation you are probably
using lots of lots of partners lots of
vendors and so we we continue to invest
in our partner ecosystem and finally we
we have lots of customers from all kinds
of scales all kinds of complexities all
kinds of industries and ranges and
they're all eager to discuss to share
their stories in their journeys with you
guys here and potentially hopefully next
year some of your logos will be up here
as well well without further ado I'm
gonna welcome Brooke and Kevin on stage
to share their story was good morning
everybody everyone enjoying the
conference so far
and thanks to Tino for kicking us off
here and helping us up helping us put
our presentation together so my name is
Rick Rainmaker I've been with Home Depot
about seven years and I'm part of the IT
team that's responsible for data and
analytics for the enterprise so my team
is responsible for all the data
engineers that that are moving all the
data into the warehouse and making
available for consumption across across
all the different business areas Home
Depot is doing a lot of things on the
Google cloud we've we were here last
year heard us talk a little bit about
our dot-com sites we got a lot of other
groups using the Google cloud as well
today we're gonna talk a little bit
about our journey in the data analytics
space
so first slide so hopefully everyone
here knows Home Depot right so we're the
number one home improvement retailer we
got a bunch of cool stats on the slide
about
the size of our organization if you
haven't been to Home Depot lately I
encourage you to check it out it has
changed quite a bit we got a lot of cool
and new and innovative products on the
floor we're growing our services
business so if you're not a
do-it-yourself type person and you want
you to do it for me we have that
available as well
we are starting to put lockers in our
stores so if you buy online and pick up
in the store you can just get you can
just pick up your products in those in
the lockers lots lots of good things
going on we're expanding in the Softline
business lots of really cool things
happening at the Home Depot but in short
we're a big we're complex and we're a
very data-driven organization for a lot
of our decision-making which kind of
makes my job really really cool most
days so our plans to talk a little bit
about what led us to migrating our
warehouse to the cloud well Kevin I'll
jump on stage and talk through a lot of
the technology and architecture
decisions and then we'll wrap up with
some of the winds and the learnings
along the way so kick it off here a
little bit about the home depot
analytics landscape so we run our
business on the EDW on our on-prem etw
today so we have our lease sales
reporting that needs to go out to the
field we have all of our supply chain
forecasts for making sure all the right
products make it to the stores we have
all our marketing campaigns that go out
to to all our consumers that comes off
the data in the UW all our event
reporting for Black Friday red white and
blue sales all of the store performance
scorecards for Monday morning
reporting at the stores all of this is
coming off our EDW and and needs to be
there on time and be accurate every day
so we have very strict SLA s and we have
a wonderful business community that lets
us know whenever we miss it and we don't
have our data there that's accurate so
so that's kind of little bit of our our
world but it is very operational and
part of what we do all day every day we
also have our business community is also
very invested in this space they we have
a very
self-service is very encouraged with our
with our business with our business
teams we have our model is we kind of
have to fold model we have more of our
data consumers and those are the folks
that are running running the stores and
running the merchandising they're
typically using Excel they're using
MicroStrategy to get the data they need
to to do their business and then we have
the data analysts and data science
community that are very they're
utilizing tableau our SAS Python all the
different tools to drive more of the ad
hoc solutions on a regular basis but one
thing that we realized is that the
demand was growing and it wasn't going
to stop so we were having a hard time
managing all that on our own Prem
environment we were told our on Prem
environment was one of the busiest
that's that's out there in the United
States and kind of proud of that but it
also presented some some additional
problems so that led us to kind of a
decision point here all right let us do
a decision point for what we were we
wanted to go going forward so our Prem
solution had served us very well it
helped us get to a consolidated single
EDW we were finding a ton of value but
we've spending a lot of time on capacity
management and every time it came to
refresh the hardware there was a large
cost outlay that we had to work through
so in two to three years prior to this
we had to do a capacity expansion and
that was about five to six months worth
of planning it was a three-day outage
there was a lot of work to to make that
all happen and then we used up all that
capacity in about a year to two years
and that capacity was gone so we're now
the point we had to do another capacity
expansion with another with all that
work ahead of us so we and then on top
of that our business teams are saying
and all the technologies expanding how
do we start doing more and more complex
analytics in that space so that's what
kind of led us to having to do something
a little bit different and kind of
really a migration to modern and modern
analytics so we started taking a look at
what what that would look like to move
to a modern analytics platform and we
know we wanted a world-class platform
lettest used management Python notebooks
get into the machine learning we wanted
to make sure our analyst
munity stayed very self-sufficient and
we wanted to make sure we were solvent
for a lot of the challenges within the
development side as well so we are those
were our objectives so we did go through
a pretty in-depth analysis of the
different platforms that are available
and we did pocs with you name him we did
it with them for the most part we also
did a very detailed I rely so he s cost
was a big piece of this and we did do
our homework there from an ROI
perspective to make sure we understood
all the different cost differences and
we also spent a lot of time
collaborating across all of all of the
key stakeholders security was probably
one of the biggest ones we worked with
along with our infrastructure teams as
well as a lot of the different business
teams as well and as a result of all of
that analysis obviously that led us to
select the Google cloud platform is
specifically bigquery to help us with
this with this journey so I'm gonna turn
it over to Kevin and he's going to kind
of walk through some of the technology
and architecture decisions that we that
we made Thanks thank you so as Rick said
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
right if you look at large enterprises
and legacy data warehouses these are
large investments a lot of data a lot of
people basically relying on this so if
you're about to pick up and change
everything that you've known and move it
we basically said let's start with our
wish list what can we do so we put
together this wish list of items and we
kind of categorized it for you so what
we decided to do was if we're gonna go
through this effort we were gonna go all
in we weren't just gonna pick up some
stuff and move it you know do some Iyaz
stuff and try to move things in we
decided if we're gonna do this we're
gonna modernize everything so we right
away said we don't want a port we knew
this was a huge step so if we're gonna
get to a modern platform it required
that level of trust and that level of a
leap to get there the next thing we did
was as Rick said we we run the business
on this this is every day it's required
so we needed a date I mean
agile practices right you try to work on
iterations and you deliver when you can
but we have real dates we have real
timelines and we don't want to have
people between systems for that long so
we chose a time and we gave ourselves a
couple years to get there this is not a
minor undertaking but we knew as part of
that as well
as we needed to be agile and what we
were doing we were gonna learn as we go
we're also we're working with the Google
team on features that weren't available
yet in bigquery and we're pushing in
terms of things that we needed and to
run our business on the platform so we
knew part of that would be to be agile
and we would have to change along the
way when we look at the people that were
involved right so we have not only our
analysts but our folks that run the
platform we said what do we want to do
with them right so if we're gonna make
this big change we have to first adopt
new practices so part of Home Depot's
general change has been we want to you
know adopt full stack teams localized
very common but in a data warehouse
space that's kind of a novel or a newer
idea it's happening more and more now
but a couple years ago it wasn't very
prevalent we also want to invest in all
the newest technologies so the cloud
involved as well as all the things
surrounding that and we wanted to make
sure that no one was left behind so we
wanted to have a learning path for all
the folks that knew maybe the old set of
tools or the old set of technologies to
move over to the new platform and have
the time to learn that platform when you
look at the tech what we we made some
big decisions here are our teams on Prem
that run our data you know in our data
centers all of our technologies they do
a great job
but that's a large investment and a lot
amount of time so we wanted to use as
much managed services as we could so
what as Rick said when we evaluated
different cloud offerings that was a
huge thing we didn't want to have all
that stress of the DevOps it's hard
enough to make sure the data is right
delivered on time and with all the
changing requirements and the biggest
takeaway from that is we wanted to scale
up and down faster Rick showed you the
chart of the CPU use right if we wanted
to grow that very quickly
that's a multi-month effort right large
dollar times with the cloud you're able
to scale up much quicker so that was a
huge
for us one of the things we also decided
to do was around ETL tools so there's a
lot of great tools out there informatica
Benicia Oh pick your favorite one we
decided as part of this change as well
that if we're going to be modernizing
the platform that we were going to
modernize the way that we brought the
data into the platform so we took a much
more developer centric role so today
where we are most of the ETL and the
data pipelines our code driven and their
developer driven and they're using
modern tools and we don't really focus
on some of those classic tools there's
nothing wrong with them
it's just choice that we made so from
this wish list we basically said ok how
can we achieve this
so short I'll fast forward the answer
everything on here we did so luckily we
had great support from our leadership
team and it drove us to an architecture
that will walk you through so we're
gonna take a little bit of time with
this and walk you through all the
different pieces of how we did this so
let's start with the capture part so
looking at this from left to right so
down at the bottom our OLTP sources so
well LTP is our operational systems
where you place orders sales through the
front end registers all of the
interactions with the company all of
those are going to remain in those
operational systems they may move over
time but they are where they are today
we have what thousands of data bases
file sets all over the place on improv
customers from partners as well as
streaming messages we have a lot of
things that are moving all the time all
these things have dependencies and
they're all scheduled and they have
tight timelines on them
so our on-prem scheduling is Tivoli
workload scheduler so our one of our
requirements is that we have to wait
when a workload is done we have to be
able to pick that up from a dependency
point-of-view and then be able to move
it for our main scheduling though within
the cloud we didn't want to bring that
product out so we use Jenkins as a way
and we script that environment to
basically act as that bridge into the
way that we're moving so here you'll see
Hadoop with a fancy name data Factory
that's our name so one of the things we
wanted to do with all the complexity
in the data center with all these
databases with all these cues and all
these files moving around if you look at
that surface area there's a lot of
systems and firewalls and you know a lot
of things you have to jump through so we
didn't want to expose all of that and
all that complexity and all that work
each time a team needed to move a
different data source out to the cloud
we have invested in Hadoop a long time
ago so we have a large aunt Prem Hadoop
infrastructure so we the team's knew how
to move data to that platform it was
also very well secured isolated
segmented and it scaled really well on
Prem so we made the choice of using that
platform as a basically saying get the
data here if you and all the teams knew
how to do that it's relatively easy
within the company if you can get it
there we can then create a factory or a
pipeline to move it out it's
bi-directional so that basically is
hiding all of our complexity of our data
center and all the complexity of those
other systems I'd say you know when we
first started we had a lot of teams we
built probably four or five different
versions of this but we've centralized
on one version because the more we can
have one way of doing it it makes it
easier for all those dependencies and we
don't have teams spending time on
plumbing code right it can basically
move a lot faster so the capture side
that's kind of the story we are making
use of that large infrastructure we have
so our next part is really hey how do we
get it out to the cloud so we there's
many ways companies can peer with Google
we use our own way it doesn't really
matter the company we're going through
but we have large 10g connections
through multiple connection points from
our data centers and our partners into
Google the first thing we do is we
basically wanted to get the data to the
cloud so classic data Lake right the
buzzword around getting it there but for
us what that really means is source
similar data from those systems in the
format that it was typically landed into
a GCS storage bucket or into a bigquery
table in its raw format so that's source
similar minimal changes so I'll give you
a sample change right if it's coming out
of an older mainframe system the
episodic to ASCII translations have been
done any character set adjustments those
things we take care of
but once it lands there it's not been
modified it's basically as it was from
that source system so that's a
relatively easy step we've got that on
print piece we move it out
now we're really into the processing
phase we've got it there so the next
part is classic ETL or ELT
you know transformations that you have
to do on that Don those data sets as
well as we have streaming datasets so we
have a lot of sources of sales of
inventory of order stuff that's
basically moving out of those source
systems in real time so we wanted that
to flow into the system as well in real
time so we have all these different ways
so most of our processing that we do
today it's either a lot of it as
bigquery within sequel itself we use
dataflow we use some custom java running
an app engine we have a wide variety of
ways again with the full stack
development teams they have some freedom
to choose amongst those platforms based
on what's the right use for their use
case so the processing is much more
fluid but we tell the teams is basically
start with bigquery if it works there
it's easy it's very easy to do it in
sequel there's a lot less code to write
you can go a lot faster if you need
something more custom then basically
head that direction if you need to for
streaming what we did is on Prem we use
a lot of legacy or older systems like
WebSphere MQ or ActiveMQ different
things we also have some Kafka as well
in the newer systems we've written it we
basically wrote a part that runs on our
Hadoop platform that moves that out to
Google pub/sub so all of the streaming
stuff ends up with all those payloads
into the pub/sub messages so from there
that's where a lot of the app engine
pieces pick those up and then they begin
to transfer them into bigquery so that's
how the streaming works but then we had
two real big parts of that that we
wanted to kind of go into first was what
we call our building blocks so Home
Depot it's a complex enterprise we have
a lot of domains so domains you know
orders customers finance supply chain
merchandising there's a lot of different
areas so the building blocks for us are
those independent areas of data that are
arriving so there's a large domain in a
series of subdomains under those but
they're landing into those basically non
integrated domain specific areas
but as they're landing their landing in
bigquery and they're in optimize
performance structures that they're able
to read from very quickly and they're
able to join they're still able to be
used for any of the downstream
processing but they're not integrated
with other parts of the different
domains so the next phase of that is we
really kind of take in a we call an ATS
analytical data set it's really working
backwards from your analyst or your user
in terms of what different domains do
they want brought together so think
about it as either a materialized view
or a view without actually materializing
in terms of just a query set that's
driving against a series of those but
most of the time it's a materialized
view so we create another set of tables
we then bring all the different building
block domains together will collapse
dimensions we'll do things to make it
very performant we also use nested
structure here so we'll talk a little
bit about how we use nested structures
inside a bigquery to do that but the
idea here is these ATS is these
analytical data sets and these building
blocks are the direct things that direct
data sources that are analysts are going
to use to basically query the data sets
and drive the downstream so they have to
be performant almost all if not all of
them are basically in bigquery today
with a very few exceptions so the next
part of that is our use case so how do
our analysts use this so we've kind of
got two different camps we've got our
typical business analysts that are using
more structured or reporting tools
standard bi things tableau at scale if
you're not familiar as an OLAP cube that
reads off of bigquery MicroStrategy
which is a more classic reporting and
SSIS which is cubes using Microsoft
technology our data scientists are doing
much more active more newer things with
ml data labs and we still have a lot of
our in sass in the environment as well
so they're basically reading out of
these data sets they have requests and
we want these to be self served so the
tableau teams once we get them out there
we have tableau running out at Google as
well so they are able to get instances
running out there they can connect to
the data sets they can then build
self-service reports they need data or
other components
they can look at the different datasets
pull from any of the values they can
read from them and then if they don't
have the data set they'll work with our
analyst teams and we can help them get
the new data sets brought in okay so
kind of a quick review of what products
do we use so we use GCS we use pub/sub
heavily dataflow bigquery we do use
datastore from our compute side we use
App Engine GCE and gke as well stack
driver for monitoring analytics we're
using data lab which is one of Google's
products and we're beta testing data hub
data prep and bigquery UI which one I
think announced today but we've been
using that for a while on the Home Depot
side we have written our own tools to
basically supplement some of these
things that we made it easier for our
internal teams to use we call them the
data pipeline and analytics engine some
sequel editing tools and we basically
provided a data catalog to be able to so
the teams can find the data we have a
large set of data one of the things that
makes home depot complex and is the wide
number of businesses we do under one
roof you know if you think of paint and
tool rental there are large complete
businesses under our roof outside of
just to pick up the merchandise and go
out the front
so those domains make that really
complicated so finding a lot of the data
and connecting it together can be a
challenge for the business one small
colored here when we first started
looking at this and we showed you in the
earlier slide we did have a large Hadoop
platform we do not use data proc we
basically don't have much of the Hadoop
stuff we rely on bigquery for that use
case so we didn't really bring a lot of
the Hadoop stuff forward nothing wrong
with the product it was just hey we said
we're doing a leap so we jumped on to
bigquery
we do have some of our data scientists
and some of the teams that do use the
product it's there's nothing wrong with
it but our core EDW doesn't use it a lot
okay so what else did we do from an
architectural point of view so if you
guys are familiar with any of the EDW
things we did do some changes here so
one thing I'll show you our slot
hierarchy keynote showed you how that
works
i we take credit for kind of pushing a
little bit to get that out there and
we'll show you our slot map and what it
looks like so we'll show that a second
the advantage of that is what we found
is that it allows the teams within the
company to have a fixed amount monthly
that they're willing to you know X X
number of slots they can pay for it can
be dedicated to them when they need it
so if they need more they can buy more
and the best part with the hierarchy is
if like you said if they're not using it
other parts of the company can share so
everybody who goes into that platform or
into that structure everybody wins
because you'll at least get what you
paid for and chances are you'll get more
and we use that excess capacity amongst
all the different teams all the time so
it allows you to plan for peak but
everybody wins another part we made a
big decision in our older system we used
a lot of surrogate Keys so you're coming
out of the operational systems there's
nothing wrong with surrogate Keys but we
were putting surrogate keys onto every
table and then we had translations back
to natural Keys so we made a decision
when we moved over here that we're gonna
have everything in its natural key
format we have a couple structures that
still use surrogate Keys when you're
combining disparate domains possibly
from different business units where the
keys don't match very well so they're
not eliminated but we basically reduced
them as kind of a standard way that we
went in and we'll talk a little bit
about nesting so we do use nesting so if
you're not familiar in bigquery you can
use a nested structure it allows you my
favorite example think of a order with
you bought three things those three line
items can be all within one row as a set
of repeating values and you can query
within sequel and it's one one row but
allows you to have more performance in
terms of data elimination you can get
right to that row
well you'll also use a nesting to in
some cases in those analytical data sets
to collapse some of the dimensions or
some of our master data tables into
those so there might be org structure or
codes tables or other things that can be
present in the data set so you don't
have to do joins so we use nested
structures and we collapse them into
that row as well the other thing we do
is the last one is really Google
projects and views so we use Google
projects the company we
have a lot of Google projects and we use
them to our advantage so a lot of our
data sets as they come in we have data
projects broken up by domain that's
where all of the ETL pipelines all the
ingest and all of that works it's all
contained it's managed by IT it's
delivered out to those other systems but
it's a place that basically controls the
data and and you saw in some of those
building blocks they land there anyone
can read them so we grant access to them
but it's all there but it isolates and
separates the different teams so they
don't step on each other so we have
about nine of those areas and we can add
a new one if we need as the company
grows we use views as well so bigquery
provides views but we use projects as
views to allow us to control the access
so we can put different folks in terms
of I am roles or things into different
groups into those projects and we can
control the access there might be PII
feels that they can or can't see or
other data sets that we can use those
projects so we make use of Google's just
part of GCP projects and views part of
bigquery extensively to basically
monitor it so we don't have one big
project with all of our data in it it's
just too much so we make use of that so
here's our hierarchy it's a little bit
crazy so I'll walk you through it so the
way it works if you're not familiar with
hierarchy so there's two ways right it's
bigquery you can do page your query it's
a pretty standard way or there's a big
query slot structure with this it's a
fixed dollar that you can have per month
and you can basically lay out a series
of hierarchies so what we've done is we
have different parts of the companies
and different they're all off of a root
node so the way hierarchies work is
sibling share first so anything that's
across if there's extra slots available
it'll share two siblings first so if I
go to the lowest part of the tree on the
bottom left for example those two nodes
and that bottom left corner will share
first so if either one of them need it
they share amongst themselves before it
would go up and that works for every
part of the tree so what we have is all
the different groups in the company from
our dot-com teams to our engineering
teams to our security teams that all
have different slot allocations
everybody's off of our root node because
everybody wins there's no loss here you
always get a guaranteed
and there's a good chance you're gonna
get more than you paid for it and that's
what we found I mean it works really
well so if you're familiar with Hadoop
it's very much like the capacity skill
you know schedule it works the same way
but it's really valuable for us it also
with a guaranteed minimum it allows you
to control your SLA s and gives you more
fine-grain so what we do then is we
attach projects into those different
buckets so like I said Home Depot we
have a lot of projects and we can attach
them at different resource nodes that
resource nodes then grants some of the
amount of slots that they need and if a
team needs a different one and they want
to buy let's say we've got a general SLA
bucket that's where we put all of our
workloads that have guaranteed SLA if we
have a team that has a project that
needs a tighter SLA and we decide we
want to break that down and buy a little
bit more slots we could create another
node move that project over and they can
get that guarantee so I think when the
Google team told us when they saw this
they went oh my this is complex but it
works great and what a good story the
day we turned this on was the best day
we had in the EDW because before that we
had basically everybody sharing one big
pool and it was you couldn't control the
minimums right so everyone was competing
with everyone we the day that we turn
this on it was the we had huge workloads
everybody's jobs went through very
cleanly and it was painless so let's
talk the other big part of what anyone
considering this type of move would hit
just like we would so security is a huge
part of everything I'm not really gonna
walk through kind of the details of what
we did I'm kind of going to give you our
strategy on a strategy that you could
use as you're considering this move as
well so almost every company is gonna
have a good you know extensive set of
security guidelines that drive based on
your business what we did is we looked
at the data classifications the
separation of duties we looked at our
DLP and exfiltration requirements and we
basically developed a strategy for how
we are going to move to the cloud what
we're going to move to the cloud and the
mechanisms by which we secure it big
part of that is what we found in talking
to a lot of other retailers a lot of
other folks considering this move is a
lot of the IT teams that are more legacy
based companies when they look
cloud this is a scary thing all of a
sudden we're gonna have all this data
together in a large area it's a big deal
so we built a partnership with the
security team and to tell you having
them use the platform as well it was a
huge plus so it breaks down the barrier
they're able to do more stuff in terms
of security footprint using the same
toolset that we're using for this and it
basically worked really well when we
found also is the adoption rate went up
the fear went down the understanding
really went up so the fear went down is
the wrong way it's really the
understanding of the way the technology
works but the one thing we did work
through is on-prem we have a lot of
native tools that we use for security so
as when you look at the cloud we're
basically looking at what the new tools
are basically out at the cloud and how
to adopt those so there might be you
have X tool on Prem that you use but a
tool at Google might be equivalent or
better and we would look at those
different tools so think about the
strategy that you would look at when
you're considering a move like this and
work with your security teams on that
and our end of this was really better
adoption so faster adoption but we spill
spit still put a huge focus and spend a
lot of time with their security teams
it's never out of focus it's just a
better approach to go towards that so
okay so if I could give you some stuff
some ideas in terms of how would you
start a migration similar to this so
first be agile because what you think
you're gonna do it's going to change
we've changed multiple times and being
agile approved excellent in that case
evaluate your tools you're probably
using existing tools today look at those
tools bring the ones forward that make
sense maybe adopt something new we I
think our single entry point out of our
data center was a huge plus for us it
made it a lot simpler
keep your schema so if you have an
existing set of schemas bring them over
try them in bigquery don't change
anything see if it works
optimize if it doesn't when we started
we kind of took an inverted way I would
recommend you just bring it over it move
it try it if it doesn't work then worry
about performance there's lots of dials
and things you can move we did not start
by copying the data we actually tried to
go back from source reckon
copying from your source from your
existing system use managed services we
love them couldn't recommend them more
highly and work closely with your
third-party companies right so a lot of
the tool sets may or may not be ready
for the cloud all right so I'll bring up
Rick to kind of bring you through
lessons learns and some more performance
wins
thanks Kevin not come no we'll go back
to some of the fun stuff so what is the
result of all of this great work that
kept and just walked through and that in
the team went through so and I will say
I mean in short this is game-changing
and it is in the all the additional
enhancements that are coming in there
making it even a better a better
decision for us so you see some of the
performance wins we've seen here yes
deck the deck here a little bit these
are our three best improvements that we
have your mileage may vary a little bit
on your actual performance you see but
these are real we were seeing things
that were running for eight nine twelve
hours that are now running and they're
now completing in a matter of minutes
and we had a ton of workload that we
couldn't even run on our Prem
environment because we just didn't have
the capacity there and that's and that
was that was a cool experience to be
able to see that stuff get completed and
be able to run we actually had to even
create a little bit of a problem for us
because a lot of the teams were so
enthralled with all the new stuff they
could go do we had all kinds of folks
working on new stuff on the cloud and we
kind of had to get everybody don't
forget we have to migrate all of our
stuff off the existing platform by the
end of this year so we got folks we it
was good is good problem to have so so
that's where we are from a performance
perspective from a capacity management
perspective has also been very
game-changing for us I can tell you we
had an outage in the middle of the night
we ran out of memory on one of our VMs
in the old world that would have been a
lot of work to figure out how to get
that fixed in the new world it was a
matter of bringing down the VM and
creates the amount of memory popping it
back up all stuff you guys are probably
seen and heard but for us that was a
pretty cool experience
I'll also say we have a major deployment
going last week even we just got last
week or two weeks ago and we were
running a little bit behind and getting
all of our historical data loaded into
into the cloud for this release we
worked with our Google team they swung a
bunch of slots over to us and about
eight hours notice so thank you for that
and use those slots for us to complete
that migration
on time and it was we had all that data
loaded in about a day and a half versus
how long we were we were planning on
that so from a capacity management
perspective it's been he's been he's
been pretty very helpful for us and then
from a delivery side we I mean we are
real and live and running on the cloud
at a number of key areas today we have
all of our pro reporting so all of our
we have a Salesforce out in the field
working with a lot of our our major
contracting companies we work with all
their reporting is available to them
running on the cloud all of our services
business where if you're you want to
have someone do it for you versus doing
yourself and although they're doing a
measure for you and the at your home all
of their information is available to you
on the that team on the cloud
our CEO dashboard that goes out every
week with tons of metrics about running
our business all of that is available
and runs on the cloud we have our
sharing of data with all of our vendors
that sell into Home Depot and then we
sell their products all of their data we
have pilot out to 75 vendors today so we
can collaborate on the data all of that
is available and on the cloud as well we
have all of our clickstream data from
all of our websites about 800 terabytes
worth of data clickstream data all of
that also on the cloud so this is real
this is happening and we're using it
every day for what for what we're doing
last thing I want to touch on is are
some of our learnings and there are
there are many of them we could probably
have a whole presentation on what not to
do but instead we'll focus on some of
our our key learnings I would say one of
our biggest ones was just recognizing
kind of the complexity of the change
management of my guarding to the cloud
so before we started this our team from
a IT perspective was your traditional
data warehousing team right so we had a
lot of ETL experts we had a lot of bi
experts we had a lot of sequel experts
that were all experts in the specific
tools that we were using and they were
some of the best that we had and we had
data modeling teams we had we had DBA
teams we had all the different teams
were more of this typicals center of
excellence models that many
organizations utilized and when we
decided to move to the cloud that
changed a lot and a lot of it from a
team perspective so the team now and a
lot of the folks are here in the room
they're awesome they're there Java
they're Python their sequel their full
stack their sre mind sets and that was a
major major change to move that team
from where we were to where we are today
and my advice on that one is put the
team first right so they've got this is
really really hard for the team all
these words all these new technologies
easy to say really hard to kind of
execute it so we did 10% days gave
people a chance to kind of learn
different things on the platforms and
and and take their time to go and learn
those we did a ton of training for them
in many different areas we're gonna
you're gonna make mistakes that's okay
learn from the mistakes and keep moving
and and give them the developers an
opportunity to make their own choices
right we didn't dictate you must do
things this way and that way they tried
a lot of different things and and we
landed in a pretty good spot
we'll say need to balance that sometimes
two at one point I think we had eight
data pipelines built and we kind of
realized that we probably don't need
eight data pipelines so we kind of work
through it and got to got to a good spot
on that I'll also say your productivity
velocity also takes some time to develop
you're not going to be as productive as
you were or want to be on day one so and
that's okay so kind of take your time to
get to the point where you have kind of
that velocity set for for that team and
we didn't even bother putting together a
road map on our deliveries until kind of
that velocity was set but at that point
once you kind of have a good velocity
definitely do get a road map in place
that really flips the flips the switch
from kind of learning mode into truly
delivery mode and we did that about the
end of last year and now we're we're
really executing against against our
roadmap second thing I would throw out
from a learning is to realize that this
change is just as big on all of your
consumers of the data so we spent a lot
of time on the
Teesside because we're the IT team and
we did a lot of work to get us through
this but at some point all of our our
business partners also had equivalent
amount of change and there's a number of
those folks in the audience with us here
today so we built out in analytics and
ableman team it's a small team probably
about three four or five people but
their full-time job all day every day
was to help out that analyst community
with this migration as well so they
helped out with making sure we're
aligned on the naming standards and how
we know how many projects do we need and
when do we hit the views versus when do
we hit tables
what other communing is required and
just helping out with a lot of the
overall communication it's we're a big
company it's hard to catch everybody
sure most of you guys are using a tool
like slack for your communication that's
that's been our number one tool for
communicating to folks and it also helps
all the other people go into this
journey to help each other too so we
don't know have to be the ones that
answer all the questions
oh that's been then a huge huge help for
us and then find your early adopters and
communicate those wins we've got certain
part folks in the organization that were
all in on this early and they were they
regretted helping help and move this
journey forward last thing I'll call out
too is just the new Google features that
are coming are really game-changing as
well I mean the the improvements in the
with clustering and partitioning has
been super helpful the joint performance
is improving all the time we we had to
flatten some structures to get the
performance early on we have to do less
and less of that today because of the
joint performance so thanks do you know
for all that and and so forth the slat
reservations and and so forth we're
still partnering with them a little bit
more visibility and what's happening on
the platform that's probably the next
thing where we're trying to get some
help with Google on but for the most
part we're getting what we need so in in
closing me as I said this technology
works it's really been a game-changing
for what we're doing in our environment
we have buy-in across the organization
everyone is all-in on on getting us
migrated by the end of this year and a
fiscal year our partnership with
Google's been fantastic we've learned a
lot from them
they learned a little bit from us and I
think we're set up for for analytics for
years to come so step one get your data
in place and then hopefully next year we
can talk about some really cool things
we're doing on the on the ml side
[Music]